[Applause]
fires up his first shot stolen by Joe
giggles wide open get up you got more
athletic
by Engels here boy look at the quickness
in the passing lane great ability and
you see here the dunk bowler he had six
dunks last year look at the bench love
and life builder they come back
defensively with the steel Joe
[Applause]
and then this time he pulls right up in
transition in rhythm back-to-back threes
Dewan light on him
he looks inside thanks Matt by angled
away by Gobert he runs with Ricky here's
Donovan fake the three bounce past Joe
in girls
this is fun to watch you watch Donovan
Mitchell makes the pass he turns and
goes the other way knowing that Joe
Engels gonna make this shot angles 11
three-point attempts and I look at da
man he's out of there he's like Joe I
know you got this one in buckets
look straight that was a part of their
farm to begin the game they started
committing some of the foul goes steps
back not that time rebound fought for
still alive picked up by English final
seconds then goes at the buzzer ingles
our 22
[Applause]
well there sits the screen direct quote
pixel printers his former teammate
giggles takes it right to the zone who's
not gonna while you of that letter shows
up the respect is there I just think
it's just a matter of time
he'll get his rhythm back Jackson's
three bounces off
[Music]
Joe steps back now runs inside to
control Ruby hammers in traffic
ball deflected picked up here's Joe for
three
Mojo's got his feet set when this
happens pretty much calculus [ __ ]
yeah this is it this the [ __ ] should be
looked at holy this was well off his
hand keep a track on Rubio a big part of
the game tonight he went out that for
thousands then
[Applause]
the shot clock down to six now five
bends lead with the left hand have to
kick it out Joe saved it great Dean
again they lock down Toronto and they
run Crowder back to a beef caught it low
lays it up missed it got it back Engels
Ricky in the corner for three take it
well Brad Stevens said the same thing
you know so such improvement from as
angels to go there now let's go there
we're going to give it back to Engels he
will take cheese he's going instead you
top all angles slithers in and finishes
it traded here for Trey younger number
five to
give it up angle straight away three
good he's wrapped in the net pick that
knocked around twice in Dallas they
doubled down a be out to Joe has to play
through the pain kicked up at 300 using
Joe as a primary balling engineer here's
the ingles favors tick and roll that we
all like the steady flicked sit with the
left hand it's been garnet ease inside a
seven point game off the bench stolen
Ingalls fires up a three pitch shot Joe
huge momentum shifts here get with net
oh he just plays hard lazy pass meadow
comes in steals the basketball angle
gets a wide open three breaks it up
traffic on a throw out working the
outside three seconds to shoot Joe
inside contact Oh Paul
his eight-point there's a bonus again
deflected taken away Joe outlet Dante
runs it down one man to beat his first
Miss go Barrett grabs the rebound
Rudy seventh ranked in the league in
rebounding the 13 a game Joe quarter
three Mitchell got it I like the pace to
season that franchise 19 I've been
corrected three blocks tonight for Rudy
53 on the season here's Joe on the
looking at a bucket there's one of the
all-time great three-point shooters it's
a three right there jazz defense so far
holding the Blazers is 71 points Oh
jingle and Joe goes inside and has
awarded with Collins where's angles
pick-and-roll has always been sweet
Collins tries to do the switch and get
on his non aside an angle says yeah I
know now right now in the Kyle clock
here's X of a game short gets his own
looking for help
[Applause]
averaging just under 13 points a game
there's joke turns a corner loves at
heart shot and sharp turn with the left
hand there he is back on the floor after
he tore loose valve and has to be
careful because of that so he shows the
ball lays it home
it's importantly a 3-point game that's
right 108 105 taken angles the chassé
are going to go to 500 as ricky is
fouled angles takes the three jazz now 6
of 15 again cut it to 13 good block
being drives hangs and hits the length
of Isaac come and pick the roll the
switch
it's neither surpassing plants luteum
wrong
they're what's inside goes back out its
Jolla to Joe with one key lay off that
beautiful run-in in great recognition
watch angles here you got the
switchboard Todd is out guard joe ingles
he allows Joe to get to his left hand
[Music]
shot clock under ten for ingles
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for Utah on the night this is when the
games really imbalance here
thank you the shot clock buzzer doesn't
matter now dad's at the ball
battlin inside no look joke three bang
just beat the clock doesn't play a lot
of minute to wrap this season just 12
minutes but gets the the nod tonight
now Phoenix is a team that will turn the
ball over they're almost at 16 turnovers
a game the Jazz gonna take advantage of
that just like bagels did on that
possession nice job getting to his left
hand fake off and then the layup look
how Joe shows the ball here it is taken
no if I'm rolling inside and lays it up
an end with the left hand to shoot right
the favors a 7o run to start the second
quarter there's that thick at the roll
and favorite quote bone that's five
straight turnovers
pick and roll babe's floater two more
taken over this ballgame signals gave up
the three gets it back in traffic
[Applause]
the right decision and get a bow down on
nice way that right back up and off
so three older son Jacob
shall I get bumped it over Colbert
intercepted inside with the leap by
Eagles
the gumbo takes on phase
clock ticking away knockdown by Joe
angles trailer to O'Neal inside up top
mist it favors but the follow shoe that
Donovan did a great job of disguising
that pelicans work the perimeter
knockdown by Joe great job jingle and
Joe off to Ricky he'll run baselines
feeds the ball in the middle and go
plant Randall was to a 70 in the first
half Rudy from Joe inside the big fella
with 13 it simply really doing a nice
job of setting this pick for Joe that's
the Parsons favors takes it away
[Applause]
Jonah stop and go driving again slow-mo
jump well when you could be slow mojo
and hesitate and still get to the basket
one of those teams for hands under 500
next up Brooklyn who's over the 500
market a retro occupation
[Music]
jazz shooting at a 48 percent clip 44
for the whiz Joe loose ball he's got it
Wow Korean metal fills a lame pun easy
layup at a seven-point first half we
know him as the second half man we'll
see if that holds true tonight Joe had
to beat the clock the Bank and Bank at
home
11 and 5 11 points 5 rebounds reporters
Joe on a step nice move Joey Engels
heretofore oh he got Beal baller 16 for
chewing on the bench his metal goes
inside on the kick-out loose ball table
oh here's Joe sets his feet for three
[Applause]
jiggling Joe Rubio just really started
to have the prints of this game in his
hands in that first half Joanna salad
goes on
shot counted gel is just it's just an
incredible player he just see he's got a
great IQ now no more one two three four
and five Rudy is maybe the Joe will
Roman his first bucket tuna check out
angles here just recent events with
eight in the mine thanks out the bench
Neto and Donovan along with favors set
to check back in Joe on another high lob
Oh he scored it Joe Joe Joe seed and in
good hands with Joe he tries to love it
puts too much Big Joe ticketed big fella
runs it up and hammers it down
Joe got off the floor mat 89 look inside
he got up before he takes off look at
the air kiss her him Joe go up boom
Donovan with three here's Joe pastor
hurry let's it fly up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and a deep three at the buzzer Joe at
the buzzer here nose time on that shot
clock one it gets it off in time splash
here it with Mitchell the relationship
has been a big part
let's go bear gets it Sahai nice scoop
lamp plus he got hit in the head angles
gets inside flips it up off the glass
Mike how about the handle shot clock
winding down angles angles down with 11
points 14 assists he has 9 rebounds I
didn't think this have any shot Joe gets
it back from favors plenty of time 12 on
the shot clock angles on a drive inside
block
[Applause]
it's time to really heat up cutters
back-to-back threes in 200 decrement 1
out of 2 Joe punch the sound here's Jose
pushes up hits the 3 and then watch him
afterwards there's Jay steps over the
three-point line feeds it back to Joe
don't dribble drive step back free-throw
line Jay good Joe's amazing 10 points
and fuller I know we've talked about
this throughout the year but a defensive
player of the year compares up there for
sure to talk about it though for him he
deserves it again Joe back tough back
three balls
six seen him dunk on a few players here
he's sneaky athletic six five ability is
Rudy thinking of jumps up top of the
rims flying here at Staples Center
Bingle final look off layup
beautifully done Jose first bucket in
the second half
gotta get a stop here out of an out
being on the three-point line we get the
four-minute mark Joe the Jazz would be
the bonus has to say here comes Joe
around the corner
[Applause]
Yoga teaches drops right to the rim
therefore the floaters open jazz players
whether it's Mitchell angles players in
the picker all they got to hit this shot
tonight love to look off and that is a
tough shine
Dingles knows the word what's even more
important is this is Denver's fourth
team foul at 9:33 close pass batted away
[Applause]
Allen fires down the anger to save and
favors with the bucket up to O'Neal
cross-court pass picked off by hard
deflection though by Mitchell those long
arms ingles with two on the clock
[Applause]
we had a lot of conversation with Utah
let them feel us let's be us why they
start to look like themselves dead
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content